so many facets to the corona virus
pandemic including the long term
ramifications on the oil industry and
its effect on our economy danville ed is
the secretary of the united states
department of energy and joins me now to
talk about that and more good evening
mister secretary thanks so much for
joining us this evening good evening
judge great to be with you thank you now
I understand that you had a meeting with
the president yesterday and many of
individuals in the oil industry what was
the what was the meeting about and what
came of it yes we did a judge we had a
meeting yesterday in the Oval Office the
president has been personally engaged
this is such an important industry to
America and he wanted to hear directly
from the largest companies the
independent oil companies as well as
some of the the mom-and-pop shops if you
will the smaller players in the entered
energy industry so that we could very
clearly understand what indeed this
kovat crisis this pandemic is doing to
the energy market in America it's been a
bit of a double whammy for this
particular industry we've seen demand
drop off because we're rightfully
addressing this pandemic but we've also
seen some major players in the
marketplace like Saudi Arabia and Russia
come into the marketplace and you know
provide some disruption if you will so
we wanted to hear directly from the
industry
mr. secretary explain what's going on
between Saudi Arabia and Russia well you
know there's a cartel in the in the
Middle East which everyone in America is
very well familiar with and what they
did was they got together a couple weeks
ago and they had to decide on how much
oil they were gonna produce and they got
into a bit of a spat and they couldn't
find an agreement between those two
players within OPEC and as a result they
decided to part ways well when they
parted ways they also made an
announcement that they were going to
produce more oil at a time in which the
world simply doesn't need it because
we're facing a decreased demand because
of this global pandemic so so then if it
the what about the strategic oil reserve
now I understand the president said he
was filling up the reserve because it
was so it was so inexpensive I mean a
there he is the businessman talked about
that and how does this all mr. secretary
how does this impact the ordinary
American who wants a book gas in their
car and how does this impact the United
States in terms of our being energy
independent
sure well judge you know this president
well and you know he is he does approach
this as a business person he does two
things very very well he asked himself
two important questions what's it what's
good for the country what's good for
America and then as he sees problems he
approaches it much like a business
person does so when these two players
decided to over produce and drive oil
prices down that presents a bargain to
the American taxpayer we have in America
strategic oil reserve a petroleum
reserve and now is the best time to fill
that up the government has a unique
track record over the years as we have
tried to fill this petroleum reserve
we've tended to buy high and sell low
the president doesn't do that while
prices are down we're going to we're
going to make this oil available to this
reserve we're going to fill it up right
to the top in how does the Department of
Energy right now work with Congress to
try to get funding to purchase oil well
here's what we're doing so you know we
can we can have appropriations from the
US Congress to buy oil we can also make
the storage available to the industry in
the oil business judge the way it works
is you either produce it and use it and
we can't do that today because demand is
down because we're rightfully addressing
this covet crisis or you can store it so
in this petroleum reserve we decided to
make it available to the industry so
that they would have a place for their
production to go while we address this
this economic crisis that we're in so
that's what we're doing wolf go ahead
I'm sorry so that's what we're doing
we're moving very aggressively this week
we announced that we're going to go to
market for 30 million barrels to put
into the Strategic Petroleum Reserve
which is down in the states of Louisiana
and Texas and ultimately I mean in the
end how does this affect you know you as
the Secretary of the Department of
Energy how does this how does this
impact our being energy independent I
mean we were exporting crude oils
correct that's correct so the nation is
turned
in the last four decades we've gone from
an importing nation to an exporting
nation so we're fundamentally different
in the in the in the in the world
economy today but we're also independent
from the types of actions that I
mentioned earlier so we're OPEC can
address you know shortages and they can
do there are things we no longer have to
pay as much attention to those actors as
we used to say 30 or 40 years ago we're
free to make the decisions that the
president just made let's fill up the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve while it's a
good time to do so yeah and it's
interesting I think that Russia was
claiming that they hadn't even spoken to
Saudi Arabia in the beginning of all of
this but you know I'll tell you what mr.
secretary as we go through this pandemic
it's kind of interesting how we realize
and winter woven we are in terms of some
of the other nations whether it's China
and our need to be independent of them
or OPEC and the whole lot of them but I
think we certainly have a president who
recognizes America first as the answer
to a lot of our problems
energy secretary Dan Brouillette thanks
so much for joining us tonight